I'm here to talk to you about HP - which
is a brand new thing in in core it's fun
is it secure
yeah we kind of need your help to help
us figure that out we need people
actually using it so I figured uh take
some time to kind of show people know
how how to actually use it last year I'm
standing up here we had just opened the
pull request right after I think a node
summit is when we landed it fortunately
we had lots of other folks in the in on
the node core team come around and fix
all the bugs I introduced so it's it's
working it's there it's still
experimental but we you know we really
do - we're at a point now where we need
y'all to actually start playing with it
starts kicking the tires get some stuff
out there and deployed and let us know
what works and what doesn't work so
let's get into it the hello world
classic example this is just a plain
text server for you know should be very
familiar if you're already you know
creating servers in node we we
intentionally made this as simple and
familiar as possible so you create the
server you have this server on stream
events now the one unique thing with HP
- vs. HP one is it with HP one you
generally have one request per
connection right now with pipelining you
can you know serialize that out send
multiple out but then you can you don't
can only have one request in flight at
any given point in time so you know if
you're sending data all that data has to
be transmitted before you can start
transmitting the next request to the
next response right with HP - it's fully
multiplexed so over a single connection
you can have multiple bi-directional
streams of data they're going over that
connection concurrently alright so you
don't have to wait for one to cook you
know to complete before you can start
setting the next one what's going on
here with a server on stream is this is
hiding the details of the connection you
don't see that information and it's
abstracting away the details of dealing
with those multiple connections and as
multiple streams all you're going to
deal with is just the stream mystery
represents a request and response flow
so instead of the request and response
object that you have an HTP one we have
this stream which is a duplex which is
what you use to read and write the data
you know either on the client side or
the server and we can get the request
headers in this headers argument the
stream respond this is how you tell it
okay I'm ready to start sending over
some response the argument there were
the status 200 that's an object that
with those are all of your response
headers that is required there are some
defaults in there so there's some
additional information that's set here
if you just do stream respond without
any arguments it's gonna send a 200
response so this is where you start
getting into this stuff note this this
is : status and it's like what the heck
is that that that's an hb2 requirement
they have these things called pseudo
headers they're like headers they're
encoded like headers they they're
expressed as headers but they're not
headers okay they're pseudo headers
right and if we have to yeah and there's
a handful of these there's like : status
: method : Authority there's a handful
of these and you're not allowed to make
up your own so if you try to add your
own : whatever it's going to complain
until you know you can't do that so we
have a handful of these there's some
constants in there that kind of make
this easy if you can't remember it but
you know it's just generally just the :
status and : method those are the ones
you're gonna be using most frequently
stream and again this is just the
streams API if you're familiar with
right you know reading a writing from
beta from streams within node it's all
it should all be familiar and it's just
a TCP server so the standard TCP or the
server dot listen to get this thing
listening but this is a plaintext server
so if you try to launch this and you try
to get out to your browser ain't gonna
work
but as browsers require you to use TLS
with hb2 so just slightly different
we're gonna create the you know get
assert a key we're gonna use this HP to
create secure server past that in
everything else remains the same in this
will work with browsers okay okay
I mean it's self-explanatory can you use
it yeah it's experimental so expecting
is the break we will try not to break
you at this point the API is relatively
stable we're fixing some things around
the edge cases some error cases I
uncovered a new seg fault last week
which is fun I'm doing the benchmark for
this talk so there are some things that
we're still figuring out but this is out
there you can use it there is a
production
I think it's called HTTP to live it's a
module out on NPM you can install that
and it can get up and running with live
hosting of hb2 on the internet that was
done by sebastian Decker's a fantastic
developer absolutely brilliant engineer
helped us with a lot with this early on
so let's talk about kind of how you
could use it though you can use the core
API so that's fine those work you can
also use some frameworks so fast if I
Matteo just being matteo looked at this
and said ah yeah I want fast body to do
this so just by setting HP to true and
the festivai configuration it will
automatically start using HP to add to
the covers and things just continue to
work so any of your existing fast fight
code will just start using HP - under
the covers same thing with rest if I
another one out there another fantastic
frameworks it's a that's used set the
keys tell it using HP - and you're off
and running
all right again this is something you
can go off play with this today use a
newer version of node node 10 no date
newer versions of no date I should have
all this in there and it should just all
work this is a fun one you can use
happen you can do this was happy no
changes were required for happy not to
do this hb2 has what's called a
compatibility mode yes there are these
HP to specific api's but it could also
work just like an HP one server there
are some nuances there are some things
that are missing for example the the
status message you know like 200 ok
right or I came over the I'm a teapot
you know message connect it that doesn't
exist in in HP 2 anymore so you can't
set a status message all you can just
set it
and a status code right so there's some
differences but for the most part when
the compatibility mode is completely
transparent so you can take this happy
server and you know as its listener give
it an HP two server and it just works
and happy as using HP - now it's sucking
with Aaron yesterday it was funny he was
saying well yeah he wants to use HP two
more but he's looking for somebody to
actually give him a use case for it we
need people to actually come up with
some really good use cases in
implementations of this to allow us to
evolve these interfaces more right we've
got it to a point we need to in order to
get it to you know we get it get it
evolve more we need to have folks
actually using it it took you believed
nodes almost almost ten years old it's
amazing right right we're coming up on
our ninth year now it's taken about nine
years to really get that HP one
interfaces like whether really you know
hardened and secure and working well
yeah this has been like two years HP -
so we're a bit behind there's more work
that has to get done on this so what
about the mill we're yeah reverse
proxies are interesting if you go out
and do a Google search for nginx and HP
- on the back end on the front end it
works great on the back end from from
the from the edge back they say yeah
sorry
you don't need HP to just use HP one
back there you control that environment
open as many connections as you want
you're not gonna see any advantage so
using HP - now there's you know there's
still discussion going on about this but
a lot of the middleware vendors do not
support HP - from the edge back to your
origin server alright so you're going to
run into some issues if you're trying to
use HP - in a production environment
that's using nginx or these other
commercial reverse proxies so I'm sorry
I do hope the cute kitten help you know
helps here he is adorable
so uh there are there are some
alternatives though ng hpx it's part of
the ng HP - project which is the
dependency node uses to enable all of
this it has a reverse proxy that does
support HP
1 2 2 2 2 1 2 2 2 it has a variety of
options there it's very simple to get
set up and and works really well it's
just hasn't quite been around as long as
nginx and doesn't have all the bells and
whistles right another one again this is
Mateo being Mateo he's like I can do
this so it created festivai HP proxy
which will you know you just plug it
into it too fast if I tell it you're
using HP 2 and it'll just proc you these
things and and what this one is nice
because you can do some additional stuff
if you need to transform the data as its
passing through you can do that with
this one so definitely worth playing
around with this and with it being Mateo
it's fast uh how's the performance after
parents thought yes that I have to I
feel like I have to qualify this this is
an on-air and approved benchmark right
so what are you know it's not
necessarily a realistic workload it's
just we wanted to test HB 1 versus HB 2
on one very simple thing so two servers
HP 1hp 2 both of them are serving up a
file one is using HP one the only way we
can do this right now is through the FS
create read stream great say a readable
stream within within know that we can
pipe that file content back out to the
response in HB 2 we're using this new
method called respond with file the
difference between these two and it's a
great read stream will create the file
and asynchronously read from it but it
pulls those chunks of data into
JavaScript passes and back down some
native a couple of times right respond
with file does everything at the native
layer so it opens the file up and has
all of the the data transfer occurring
strictly at the native layer and this is
you know you wouldn't use this if you
need to transform that data but if all
you're doing is serving the file this is
significantly faster just doing
everything at the native layer alright
so the setup here is we're gonna use h2s
you load which is a benchmarking tool
that comes as part of a ng HTP - we're
gonna go it's right 20,000 requests
headed the typo and
- c8 and - t8 is supposed to say eight
concurrent clients and eight concurrent
worker threads we're gonna do a max of
500 concurrent requests at a time and
the payload that we're sending back and
forth is off there's a hundred and sixty
case X file again not a realistic
workload so my apologies to Aaron will
get better you know we actually need to
define a realistic workload here to give
it a true test let's look at the results
so HP one if we break it out we get
about 2,700 requests for a second and
this is running on my on my surface book
and in a VM excuse me
note some of these other numbers for
sending 1.4 7 mega bytes of header data
all right the time for request is a mean
of about one point three seven seconds
okay and the time to first byte is you
know about three or forty two
milliseconds okay so that's it's kind of
the baseline with with HTP one let's
look at the numbers for HP - we have 56
just over 5600 requests per second we've
doubled the throughput our time to
request this is the most significant
number has dropped to 140 milliseconds
because of the way HP - is doing its
multiplexing it is able to respond to
requests much faster than with with HP
one that's because of the mechanism
internally that is it's using to manage
these requests it doesn't have to do the
additional connection management
basically for each one of these things
so it's able to respond much faster now
there is a caveat here it's not captured
in these numbers but the HP - server is
using about 20% more memory to serve the
same number of requests so in the reason
for that is because of the of the
multiplexing there is additional
buffering that we have to do internally
it's got to manage the data flow right
we have to actually sequence out and
buffer the data over multiple frames
right as it's divided up across these
requests now this has all the typical
other caveats of you know it's it's an
unrealistic benchmark the the file is up
getting all that it gets cached
but it's you know it's the same caveats
for both but HP - and HP one so the
results you know it gives you a
a basic idea that there's some things
here that are much more efficient and
other things that there's still need
some additional work okay so that's
performance there's lots more to do
there lots more and we're gonna be
looking probably over the next year
doing some deep performance research on
this so hopefully that'll be coming on
the mic that available says in here from
web blog of some performance research
that really goes into the internals now
what about WebSockets WebSockets you
know super you know super popular
everyone's using them yeah
you can't actually use WebSockets if
they CH beat you so the mechanism for
bootstrapping the use of WebSockets uses
the upgrade header and hp1 that doesn't
exist in hp2 anymore so you can't
bootstrap the use of HP of WebSockets
from an HP two connection you can use
the use them together alright I said we
have this compatibility mode that allows
a HP two server to act like an HP one so
this is the fun bit of code that creates
the HP two server right uses the
compatibility mode you know I said
before it was the stream here we're
telling it no no no just use the request
in response this is where it starts
acting like an HP one server and we have
this allow HP one and true what this
tells us is only when we're using TLS it
doesn't work with plain sex connections
what this says is we can have this
server listening on this port speak
either HP to or fall back to HP one and
when you're falling back to HP one you
do have the upgrade mechanism so you can
connect a WebSocket server to that and
have it just work so in this case we
have a server that is supporting HP 1hp
two and WebSockets whether or not that's
a good thing to do is still up in here
like I said we have to do a lot of
performance testing on this it works but
you're you're asking your one node
instance to do quite a bit of quite a
bit of stuff here as a best practice
it's probably a good idea to offload
that WebSockets traffic to a different
process but this is just fun I mean it's
just you know neat did we connect we can
actually do this and a ton of work has
been done by the node core team too
to make this compatibility layer just
just work so this one's fantastic um
let's see what else can we do
server-sent events are fun the server
push streams for non browser clients hb2
to the browser is it is fantastic it's a
proven use case you know Google's been
doing this for for a long time you know
all of the you know all of the mobile
devices you know Google in iOS all of
the browsers major browsers support this
and you can do HP to to you know for in
the browser
most of the the proxies like I said they
support it from the edge forward and it
just works as great for non browser
clients the promise of hb2 is really
compelling there's a number of really
interesting things you can do with with
the server push i'ma show example you
know you have on the client side how you
can how to tap into this and then
another fun thing creating proxy tunnels
with connects so do some examples kind
of might be a little bit hard to read in
the back but service and events
basically you're opening a channel from
the server and pushing it out to the out
to the client now what HP bonus is
typically done you know if you have
pipelining set up properly you can even
accomplish but it's typically like long
polling it's up its technique now but it
typically ends up being multiple
connections to the server from the
client with HP - we have the option of
doing server sent events over a single
connection just with multiple streams
right so we open the connection here we
send some HTML down that creates an
event source which is basically opening
another request channel from the server
number from the client side it looks
like a long pole okay
but from the client and from the server
side we're just opening another stream
on a already established connection and
it's just pushing data out incrementally
and then there's a number of different
ways we can do this accomplish this with
HP - this is just you know one of one of
the examples for server pushed streams
there is a client API so far I've only
shown the server API this is on the
client side it's not great but it works
so we can create a client we connect and
again this works
differently than the HP one because
there is no record there's no agent
right and a a single connection needs to
support multiple requests so there's not
just a HP get where it's just opens the
connection does a request returns and
closes it we have to keep that thing
open because we might send multiple
things over it so we have this
distinction between client and request
right and here there's some defaults
when you do client requests by default
it's sending a get to the answer just
the default path which is just a slash
all right so we're sending that to the
server push streams only work when
there's an initial request so the client
has to say I want something and then the
server can say okay here's ten things
somebody gave you if it knows that
you're going you know if it knows it's
going to you're going to need those
things then it can start sending it but
it has to wait for that request so we're
sending a request first and then we're
going to wait for a stream to be created
and what we get back is just a stream
that duplex we can read data from it so
we can start allowing the server to open
this channel and push data out browsers
do not give you this level of access to
a push stream what they allow you to do
is basically pre populate a cache right
so if somebody you know if some script
on that client requests a file that file
data already happens to be in a cache
but when you have a programmatic client
right you can use this as a
bi-directional data flow between your
client your server there are some
amazing possibilities with this when
you're talking about communication with
these non browser clients particularly
within a closed network there's some
amazing things you can do here and I'm
yeah and I want to stand up you know be
out in the audience next year and hear
about some of the amazing things folks
are doing with this stuff so all right
so proxying using kinect kinect kinect
is fun if you're not familiar with it
basically it's a HP method that allows
you to establish a proxy tunnel through
HTP it's been around forever for HP one
for quite a while the fun thing that you
can do with HP 2 is you can have
multiple proxy tunnels through a single
connection so imagine a single client
opens a single connection to a server
but that server is actually routing
those tunnels out to multiple backends
and it's all
through one connection from the from the
client to the server I was exactly what
this is doing it's gonna be a little bit
hard to read all of these slides will be
online if you want to kind of take a
look at it and play with it this
particular example was just taken from
our test cases in node core so it's not
very sophisticated all it does creates a
socket or a TCP server and has the HP to
server proxy connect request to it and
it's passing data back and forth that
going in back and forth ah let's see
what about debugging this is an
important one unfortunately the tools
aren't great yet
you can use like Wireshark to monitor
the traffic here there is the ng HP to
clients and actually I think it's just
ng HP is the command line this is the
the it's not part of node but this is
just the part of the project that we're
using to enable all this it's a
fantastic client has a verbose mode
where you can see exactly what's
happening going back and forth on a node
server side we have a couple of
environment variables you can enable I
have runtime to get very detailed
questionably useful information out
about what's happening within node and
we're working on making that better all
right you can use the the vs code in
chrome dev tools to debug I use two Bs
code extensively and I just use B as
code just while I'm developing node in
general it's fantastic idea if you're
not using it go use it I use it C but
you know it's debugger to actually go
through step through what's happening
within with a node on and all this and
if you want even more and it's an insane
amount of detail the enable the trace
events for racing cooks and you'll see a
ton of information about the sessions
and the streams that are that are going
on all right what's left to do this you
know
not sure if you try at home yes yes
traders don't go do some stuff with it
let us know what works more importantly
let us know what doesn't know it doesn't
work if you find security
vulnerabilities especially we do have a
node core does have a bug bounty program
that we run if you do find security
vulnerabilities you can report those
and possibly get a reward for that but
the biggest thing we need right now is
feedback from implementers you know you
know there's a ton of questions that
that are not answered and we can we
could come up with premature answers for
those things but we don't know which
ones are important to answer we don't
know if the api's are exactly what you
all need it's a like I said it took
years for us to fit you know to get all
this worked out for the HP one
implementation and those api's it's
still it's gonna take several years for
us to kind of get this right and yes
it's still experimental which means we
can make changes that might break code
but we'll let you know in advance this
thing is very very close to coming out
of experiment so we're just trying to
work out those last few pages so we need
you all to actually go out and inward
and work on this so I'm wrapped up early
that's that's nice thank you
I thanks to both IBM and near forum I
started this work on HP to when I was
working with IBM and they've been a and
they funded that then so it's fantastic
they were able to do that near form has
been just kind of let me run with it
since so thank you to both of them and
that's it I can open up to questions if
y'all having
[Applause]